- Le 4 août 2020 restera à
jamais gravé dans ses chairs.
Shady Rizk a eu 350 points de
suture. On le voit ici, au pied
du bureau vitré où il se
trouvait, et où il filmait,
le soir de l'explosion.
Voici ce qu'il a vécu.
- Oh shii... What the F&!?
- Il ne compte plus les séances
pour enlever les morceaux de
verre. Il y en a encore pour
des années, selon ses médecins.
SHADY RIZK, ingénieur et
survivant de l'explosion
- Cette détresse psychologique,
près d'un adulte sur deux -
la ressent encore un an plus
tard, selon un rapport
de l'UNICEF.
La photographe, Sayde Jabra,
voulait déjà émigrer au Canada.
L'explosion a tout précipité.
SAYDE JABRA, photographe
libanaise installée à Montréal
- On voulait donner encore une
chance, et encore une autre
chance. Et... et le jour où
l'explosion s'est passée,
le 4 août 2020, c'est là qu'on a
décidé que... on ne peut plus
vivre dans un pays où on n'a
plus de sécurité pour nous et
même pour les enfants.
- Elle se rappelle la veille
de son départ, fin août.
- J'étais au port, j'étais en
train de pleurnicher là-bas,
et je me suis dit : comment je
vais quitter ce pays?
Ils ont déchiré nos coeurs,
ils ont détruit notre avenir,
notre futur. Tu as plus de
rêves.
- "Ils", ce sont
les responsables politiques
libanais qui ont permis
le stockage du nitrate
meurtrier. Leur impunité, mise
en évidence dans un rapport de
l'organisme Human Rights Watch,
ajoute la colère au traumatisme.
Sans avancée judiciaire
au Liban, les avocats
tentent d'autres pistes.
Me MICHEL EL MEOUCHI,cofondater,
"Justice for Lebanon"
- D'intenter des procès,
par exemple en France,
pour les ressortissants français
qui ont été affectés.
Et au Canada, entre autres,
pour des ressortissants
canadiens, dont la jeune
Alexandra Najar, qui avait
trois ans, et qui a été tuée
dans l'explosion.
- Qu'il se soit écoulé une
année, sans réponse, choque
autant là-bas que dans
la diaspora.
LAMIA CHARLEBOIS, consultante en
RP libano-canadienne à MTL.
- C'est l'énormité de
l'impunité, de l'injustice...
il y a eu aucun procès.
Ce sentiment d'impuissance et
d'injustice est très violent,
très, très violent.
- Elle est ici depuis trois
décennies. Et la conjonction
de cette catastrophe avec
la pandémie a encore compliqué
les choses.
- Avant, on partait aussi très
souvent au Liban, la diaspora
retournait au pays pour
réinjecter de l'argent,
pour refaire rouler l'économie
et le tourisme. La pandémie a
bousillé tout ça. Donc il y a eu
un an où les gens ne partaient
plus.
- Et sur place, la situation
s'est dégradée rapidement.
La monnaie a perdu 90 %
de sa valeur. Les Libanais
vivent avec les pénuries
d'électricité, d'essence,
de médicaments.
La rage est palpable.
Mais se transformera-t-elle
en une nouvelle révolution?
- On passe tellement de temps
à s'assurer qu'on survit.
On a rarement le temps de voir
plus loin et d'essayer de penser
révolution ou autre. Ils nous
ont vraiment... nous sommes
comme les souris dans
un labyrinthe, en train de
chercher la sortie. On n'a pas
le temps de lever le nez et voir
plus loin.
- Sayde, elle, va exposer
ses photos à Montréal, au profit
des Libanais. Quant à Shady,
il aimerait suivre le même
chemin.
- Dieu m'a donné une autre
chance de vivre. And I'm so
lucky. So, je ne veux pas
la vivre dans un pays chaotique.
Je veux vivre ma nouvelle vie
dans un pays paisible et sûr,
comme le Canada.
- Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, M